Before we get started today, I'd like to ask you our listeners to take a moment to fill out our listener's survey. We want to learn more about what you think of this podcast, who you are, and what you'd like to hear from us. So if you could, after you listen to this episode, please go to our website at www. speakingofpsychology.org and look for the link to the listener's survey. We'd really appreciate it if you would take it. Thank you. Now on to the episode. About one in 36 children in the U.S. has been diagnosed with autism spectrum disorder, according to the most recent Centers for Disease Control estimates.
在今天的节目开始之前，我想请听众朋友们花一点时间填写我们的听众调查问卷。我们希望更多地了解您对本播客的看法、您的背景以及您希望从我们这里听到什么内容。因此，如果您方便的话，在听完这集节目后，请访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org，并寻找指向听众调查问卷的链接。如果您能抽空填写，我们将不胜感激。谢谢。现在让我们进入正集。根据美国疾病控制与预防中心的最新估计，美国约有三十六分之一的儿童被诊断患有自闭症谱系障碍。
Many of those children are not diagnosed until they're three to five years old, and some even later than that. Scientists used to think that it was not possible to diagnose autism at a much younger age, but recent research using artificial intelligence, brain biomarkers, and other methods has pointed to the possibility of earlier detection and earlier intervention. Today we'll talk about research on autism, autism diagnosis, and interventions. Why has the number of diagnoses risen so steeply in recent years? Why is autism so much more common in boys than in girls?
其中许多儿童直到三到五岁才被确诊，甚至还有更晚的。科学家们过去认为，在更小的年龄诊断出自闭症是不可能的，但最近使用人工智能、大脑生物标志物和其他方法的研究表明，实现更早的筛查和更早的干预是有可能的。今天我们将探讨关于自闭症、自闭症诊断以及干预措施的研究。为什么近年来确诊人数会急剧上升？为什么自闭症在男孩中比在女孩中要常见得多？
And how might these new technologies and methods change autism detection and intervention? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Geraldine Dawson, the William Cleland Distinguished Professor of Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences at Duke University. She is also director of the Duke Center for Autism and Brain Development. Dr. Dawson's work focuses on improving methods for early detection
这些新技术和新方法又将如何改变自闭症的筛查和干预？欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是杜克大学精神病学与行为科学威廉·克里兰杰出教授杰拉丁·道森（Geraldine Dawson）博士。她同时也是杜克大学自闭症与大脑发育中心的主任。道森博士的工作重点是改进自闭症的早期筛查
and intervention for autism and understanding brain function in autism. Earlier in her career, she co-developed the Early Start Denver model, an empirically validated early autism intervention that is used worldwide. She collaborates with colleagues in the departments of computer science and engineering, pediatrics, and biostatistics to develop novel digital health approaches to autism screening and outcome monitoring. Dr. Dawson has won many awards for her work, including a distinguished career award from APA's Society of Clinical, Child and Adolescent Psychop. Dr. Dawson, thank you for joining me today. I'm very happy to be here. Can you start by just giving us some background on what autism spectrum disorder is and encompasses? Because it can look very different in different people. Is that correct?
与干预方法，并理解自闭症中的大脑功能。在她职业生涯的早期，她共同开发了“丹佛早期介入模式”（Early Start Denver Model），这是一种在全球范围内广泛使用的、经过实证验证的早期自闭症干预方法。她与计算机科学与工程系、儿科以及生物统计学系的同事合作，开发用于自闭症筛查和结果监测的新型数字健康方法。道森博士因其工作荣获多项奖项，包括美国心理学协会临床、儿童与青少年心理学分会颁发的杰出职业生涯奖。道森博士，非常感谢您今天能来。我很高兴来到这里。您能否先给我们简单介绍一下什么是自闭症谱系障碍，它包含哪些内容？因为这种病症在不同人身上表现可能非常不同，对吗？
Yes, you're absolutely right. In fact, there's a saying that says if you've met one person with autism, you've met one person with autism. And the reason for that is that it is a very heterogeneous condition. So, for example, about 30% of people on the autism spectrum never learn to speak. Many may require 24-7 care to help them with their very basic needs. And at the other end of the continuum, there are individuals who are highly intelligent. We have an autistic researcher here at the center who has a PhD in physics. So there's just this huge continuum. So that does beg the question then, you know, what is autism?
是的，您完全说对了。事实上，流传着这样一句话：如果你见过一个自闭症患者，你就只是见过一个自闭症患者。原因在于它是一种高度异质性的病症。例如，大约30%的自闭症谱系人群从未学会说话。许多人可能需要全天候的照护来帮助他们满足最基本的需求。而在连续体的另一端，则是个体智力极高的人。我们中心就有一位患有自闭症的研究员，他拥有物理学博士学位。所以这中间存在着一个巨大的连续体。这就引发了一个问题，也就是，究竟什么是自闭症？
What brings all of this together? And in every case, the individual has some challenges in navigating the social world, may have some difficulty in picking up on social cues and interpreting sort of the normal type of social information, such as gestures, facial expressions. That individual also may have trouble forming social relationships. So, for example, developing peer relationships and just understanding sort of the back and forth reciprocal nature of relationships. And then there's also another category of behaviors
是什么将这一切联系在一起？在每种情况下，个体在驾驭社交世界时都会遇到一些困难，可能在捕捉社交线索以及解读正常类型的社交信息（如手势、面部表情）方面存在一定难度。该个体在建立社交关系方面也可能会遇到麻烦，例如发展同伴关系，以及仅仅理解关系中那种你来我往的互惠性质。此外还有另一类行为，
which have to do with the tendency to engage in what we call a restricted range of interest, or behaviors. So that individual may be highly interested in one topic and want to talk about that topic and spend most of the time thinking about that topic may also show some repetitive motor behaviors. And then finally, with the DSM-5, an additional trait was added, and that is differences in sensory sensitivity. So it may be sensitivity to sound or to light or to touch. And so all of these things together comprise what we call the autism syndrome. And then, you know, this may be manifest in very different ways depending on each individual. Now, some of our listeners might be familiar with the term Asperger's syndrome, but that term isn't
它们与倾向于从事我们称之为“范围受限的兴趣或行为”有关。因此，该个体可能会对某个话题高度感兴趣，并想要谈论该话题，将大部分时间花在思考该话题上，也可能会表现出一些重复性的运动行为。最后，在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版》（DSM-5）中，增加了一个额外的特征，那就是感觉敏感性的差异。因此，这可能是对声音、光线或触觉的敏感。因此，所有这些因素共同构成了我们所说的自闭症综合征。然后，你知道的，这可能会根据每个个体表现出非常不同的方式。现在，我们的一些听众可能熟悉“阿斯伯格综合征”这个词，但这个词现在已经
used now. Can you explain why that's fallen out of favor? Yeah, so Asperger's syndrome was defined as having difficulties in the areas of social interaction and communication, as well as those restricted and repetitive behaviors, but not having intellectual disability or language delay. And so that sort of beg the question of how is that different than just an individual on the autism spectrum, you know, who doesn't have intellectual disability. So, you know, there were many studies that tried to disentangle of those two ways of thinking about people on the highest end of the spectrum. And we really couldn't define any differences.
不用了。您能解释一下为什么它失宠了吗？是的，阿斯伯格综合征被定义为在社交互动和沟通领域存在困难，以及那些受限和重复的行为，但没有智力残疾或语言延迟。这就引发了一个问题：这与单纯的自闭症谱系个体（即没有智力残疾的个体）有什么不同呢？所以，有许多研究试图厘清看待光谱最高端人群的这两种方式。而我们实际上无法定义出任何差异。
The other thing is that clinicians were very unreliable in diagnosing, you know, autism without intellectual disability versus Asperger syndrome. And then finally, since many individuals are not diagnosed until later in life, it required the individual to base their symptom or their behavior on history, right? You would have to ask the individual when you were a child, did you have any difficulty developing language? And that was simply unreliable. People couldn't really remember, you know, what their language history was many years later.
另一件事是，临床医生在诊断没有智力残疾的自闭症与阿斯伯格综合征时非常不可靠。最后，由于许多个体直到生命后期才被确诊，它要求个体根据病史来陈述他们的症状或行为，对吧？你必须询问个人：你小时候在语言发展方面有什么困难吗？而这根本是不可靠的。多年以后，人们根本记不清他们的语言发展史是什么样的了。
So for all those reasons, the DSM Committee, and by the way, that's the American Psychiatric Association Committee, that comes up with the diagnostic criteria, they decided that it was best to go ahead and eliminate that. And think of autism as just a spectrum. And then some individuals also have intellectual disability and language delay. And I think that change has been good.
因此，由于所有这些原因，DSM委员会（顺便说一下，这是美国精神病学协会负责制定诊断标准的委员会）决定最好还是将其取消。并将自闭症仅仅视为一个谱系。然后，一些个体还伴有智力残疾和语言延迟。我认为这一改变是件好事。
It did create some, I think, challenges for people who really identified with having the diagnosis Asperger Syndrome, you know, so-called Aspies, or there were a lot of groups that came together to socialize that were diagnosed with Asperger syndrome. And so there was a point made that people could certainly continue to consider that, you know, as a personal way of describing themselves or personal identity. It just wasn't going to be recognized anymore by the, according to the American Psychiatric Association's diagnostic criteria. Well, that makes sense.
它确实给那些强烈认同自己拥有阿斯伯格综合征诊断的人（也就是所谓的“阿斯伯格人”）带来了一些挑战，你知道的，或者有很多为了社交而聚集在一起的、被诊断患有阿斯伯格综合征的群体。因此有人指出，人们当然可以继续将此视为一种描述自己的个人方式或个人身份。只是它不再被美国精神病学协会的诊断标准所认可。嗯，这说得通。
Well, let me ask you what we know about the causes of autism. Is it genetic? Is it caused by something that happened to the mother during pregnancy or something else? So the causes of autism are complex. I think it's first, it's important to keep in mind that autism is a condition that is a difference in the way that brain develops. And so just as in neurotypical individuals, there are many factors that contribute to how, you know, each of us has a different brain in terms of its capabilities, its strengths, its weaknesses, and how it develops. And that includes both genetic factors.
那么，请问我们对自闭症的成因了解多少？它是基因引起的吗？是由母亲在怀孕期间发生的事情引起的，还是由其他原因引起的？因此，自闭症的成因很复杂。我认为首先重要的是要记住，自闭症是一种大脑发育方式存在差异的病症。因此，就像在神经典型人群中一样，有许多因素会影响我们每个人在能力、优势、劣势以及大脑发育方面如何拥有一个不同的大脑。这其中包括遗传因素。
So autism is a highly genetic condition. It can run in families. and you do see families with multiple children with a diagnosis of autism. Interestingly, it also runs in families with other conditions such as ADHD. So there seems to be some overlap and genetically between autism and ADHD. So genetic factors are clearly contributing and they are contributing in such a way that the brain is developing differently. we know starting in the prenatal period. And we also know that during the prenatal period,
因此，自闭症是一种高度遗传的病症。它会在家族中遗传，你确实会看到家族中有多个孩子被诊断出患有趣的是，它也会在患有其他病症（如多动症）的家族中遗传。因此，自闭症和多动症之间似乎存在一些遗传重叠。所以遗传因素显然在起作用，并且它们的作用方式使得大脑发育出现差异。我们知道从产前阶段就开始了。我们还知道，在产前阶段，
anything that is going to affect the mother that also affects the brain of the baby that's developing could contribute to differences in brain development and also could, in that sense, contribute to autism. So, for example, one of the theories that is being investigated is what's called the maternal immune activation hypothesis. And what that is is a hypothesis that environmental conditions that activate the mother's immune system will influence the way that the fetal brain is developing. It used to be thought that the brain of the fetus was entirely protected from these environmental conditions that the mother may be experiencing that affected her immune system. But now we know
任何会影响母亲、进而也会影响发育中婴儿大脑的因素，都可能导致大脑发育的差异，从这个意义上讲，也可能导致自闭症。例如，正在研究的其中一个理论被称为“母体免疫激活假说”。这就是这样一个假说：激活母亲免疫系统的环境条件会影响胎儿大脑的发育方式。过去人们认为，胎儿的大脑完全免受母亲可能经历的、影响其免疫系统的这些环境条件的影响。但现在我们知道，
that actually anything that is activating her immune system during pregnancy could potentially affect, you know, aspects of the brain development, and particularly cells that are called the microglia, which are immune-related cells in the brain that actually participate in the development of synapses and the formation of the brain. So what, what? What can affect the mother's immune system during pregnancy? Really a wide range of conditions. So, for example, stress activates our immune system. Environmental factors such as toxins, so pesticides or air traffic pollution can activate our immune system.
实际上在怀孕期间任何激活她免疫系统的东西都可能潜在地影响大脑发育的各个方面，特别是被称为小胶质细胞的细胞，它们是大脑中与免疫相关的细胞，实际上参与了突触的发育和大脑的形成。那么，究竟是什么会影响母亲在孕期的免疫系统呢？实际上是范围广泛的各种情况。例如，压力会激活我们的免疫系统。环境因素（如毒素，如杀虫剂或空气交通污染）可以激活我们的免疫系统。
Having a significant infectious disease associated with high fever will obviously affect. the immune system. And in fact, there's been studies now looking at, you know, the impact of having COVID-19 during pregnancy on, you know, the neurodevelopmental outcomes of the baby, and there can be an impact. So we believe that it is this combination of both genetic susceptibilities with environmental factors, particularly those that affect the mother during pregnancies that are shaping all of our brains, right, not just in autism, but also are contributing to differences that we then ultimately would diagnose this as autism. So I mentioned in my introduction, the prevalence of ASD is much higher among boys than it is among girls, four times higher,
患有伴随高烧的严重传染病显然会影响免疫系统。事实上，现在有研究着眼于在怀孕期间感染COVID-19对婴儿神经发育结果的影响，并且可能会产生影响。因此，我们认为正是这种遗传易感性与环境因素（特别是那些在怀孕期间影响母亲、塑造我们所有人大脑的因素，不仅在自闭症中，也导致了我们最终将其诊断为自闭症的差异）的结合。正如我在引言中所提到的，ASD在男孩中的患病率远高于女孩，高出四倍，
in fact. Do researchers know why? Yes, it's been an amazing kind of phenomenon to watch the prevalence of autism increasing over the last several decades. I've been in the field for many decades now. And when I first started as a psychologist, I thought I would be this expert in helping individuals with this very rare condition. And I imagined sort of myself, I was in the Northwest then as being kind of the person that might serve people in the Northwest or the Western part of the United States. And now, of course, you know, autism, spectrum disorder is really relatively common.
事实上。研究人员知道原因吗？是的，看着自闭症患病率在过去几十年里不断上升，真是一种惊人的现象。我从事这个领域已经有几十年了。当我刚开始成为一名心理学家时，我以为我会成为帮助患有这种极其罕见的病症的个体的专家。我当时想象自己（我当时在西北地区）会成为那种可能为西北地区或美国西部地区的人们服务的人。而现在，当然，你知道的，自闭症谱系障碍其实相对普遍。
And to be truthful, we don't completely understand, you know, even the epidemiologists and experts in the area of, you know, understanding differences in prevalence and so forth, like people at the CDC, they don't fully understand why there's been an increase. But when we do study it, what we find is there really has been changes in both the diagnostic criteria, where they've now broadened somewhat from the criteria that we had early on. And then secondly, we're just so much better at recognizing autism.
说实话，我们并不完全理解，甚至连流行病学家和该领域的专家（比如美国疾控中心的人，他们负责了解患病率的差异等）也没有完全理解为什么会出现增长。但当我们对此进行研究时，我们发现诊断标准确实发生了变化，现在的标准比我们早期的标准有所放宽。其次，我们识别自闭症的能力要好得多。
And you probably yourself now can recognize autism, whereas 30 years ago you probably couldn't. So I think that we're now able to diagnose autism with individuals who have milder traits and also at a much earlier age. And, you know, keep in mind that these prevalence estimates are really based on just looking at how many times a person is, how many people are diagnosed in a particular geographic area. And so if you see, you know, if we're getting better at early detection, we're going to see these prevalence rates go up. But we don't know whether there might have been, say, environmental factors that also
你现在可能自己也能认出自闭症，而30年前你可能做不到。所以我认为我们现在能够对具有较轻特征的个体以及在更早的年龄诊断自闭症。而且，请记住，这些患病率估计实际上只是基于观察在特定地理区域有多少人被诊断出来。所以如果你看到，如果我们越来越擅长早期筛查，我们就会看到这些患病率上升。但我们不知道是否可能存在诸如环境因素之类的事情，
could have contributed to the increase. And it's also hard to know because the diagnostic criteria have changed over time. So what you're measuring is changing. And that just makes it very hard to know. Well, a lot of your work has focused on early detection and intervention. What does early mean for an autism diagnosis? At what age is it typically diagnosed? Let's start with when it can be reliably diagnosed.
也可能导致了增长。而且这很难知道，因为诊断标准随着时间的推移而发生了变化。所以你所衡量的内容正在改变。这使得我们很难确知。嗯，你的很多工作都集中在早期筛查和干预上。对于自闭症诊断而言，“早期”意味着什么？通常在什么年龄被诊断出来？让我们从何时能可靠地诊断开始。
So we know that we can reliably diagnose autism by 18 to 24 months, certainly by 36 months, but 18 to 24 months, that diagnosis is quite stable. The average age of diagnosis, though, in the United States is closer to. five years of age and even higher for families of color or individuals who may not have the resources to, you know, be able to obtain a diagnosis. So it takes many more visits to the doctor, for example, for a black child to receive a diagnosis than it does for a white child. So we know we can diagnose by 18 to 24 months. We're obviously not doing a good enough job. because the average age is much higher.
所以我们知道，我们可以在18到24个月时可靠地诊断自闭症，到36个月时肯定可以，但在18到24个月时，这种诊断是相当稳定的。然而，在美国，平均诊断年龄接近5岁，对于有色人种家庭或可能没有资源获得诊断的个人来说，年龄甚至更高。例如，一个黑人儿童要获得诊断，比白人儿童需要看更多次医生。所以我们知道我们可以在18到24个月时进行诊断。显然我们做得还不够好，
And by the way, the other thing that contributes to delay in diagnosis is being a girl. Because girls, we are just learning more about autism and girls and finding that the expression of the autism traits is somewhat different. So, as you know, in neurotypical individuals, females tend to be a bit, better at social interaction and picking up on social cues. There's been studies that have shown that, and this is true in autism as well. So you may see better eye contact and therefore many girls are missed. The other thing that contributes to missing children is when autism is combined with a psychiatric condition. So we know that, for example, about 50% of the children,
因为平均年龄要高得多。顺便说一句，导致诊断延迟的另一个因素是身为女孩。因为女孩，我们对女孩自闭症的了解越来越多，并发现自闭症特征的表现有所不同。因此，如你所知，在神经典型人群中，女性往往在社交互动和捕捉社交线索方面表现得更好。已经有研究表明了这一点，自闭症患者中也是如此。所以你可能会看到更好的眼神接触，因此许多女孩被漏诊了。导致漏诊儿童的另一件事是当自闭症与精神疾病合并时。所以我们知道，例如，大约50%的儿童，
of individuals with autism also have ADHD. And so what happens is that when a young child presents with both autism and ADHD, the ADHD symptoms tend to get more attention because ADHD is often associated with what we call externalizing behaviors. These are things like, you know, you can't sit in your seat. You might be interrupting. You can't finish things. You might be, you know, blurting out.
自闭症患者同时也患有多动症。因此发生的情况是，当幼儿同时表现出自闭症和多动症时，多动症的症状往往会受到更多关注，因为多动症通常与我们所说的外化行为有关。这些事情就像是，你知道的，你不能坐在座位上。你可能会打断别人。你无法完成事情。你可能会，你知道的，脱口而出。
And those behaviors are very disruptive and they tend to catch our attention more. And we call this diagnostic overshadowing when a person has two conditions and one is kind of more obvious. That diagnosis tends to get the label for the child and then the other one is missed. So when children have both autism and ADHD, they tend to be diagnosed at a much higher age. So, but I think the second question is, you know, when do the early behaviors or early signs of autism actually begin to emerge and how early might we be able to detect autism? So there's a lot of work going on and we've been doing some of this work in our lab as well, trying to identify autism in babies because there's been many studies now that, and some of this work was done by our team where we looked at home videos of infants who then were later diagnosed of autism. But there's been many studies that
这些行为非常具有破坏性，往往更能吸引我们的注意力。当一个人有两种病症且其中一种更明显时，我们称之为诊断掩蔽。这种诊断往往会贴在孩子身上，而另一种则被漏诊。因此，当儿童同时患有自闭症和多动症时，他们往往在年龄大得多时才被诊断出来。但是，我认为第二个问题是，自闭症的早期行为或早期迹象究竟何时开始出现，我们可能在多大程度上尽早检测出自闭症？因此，有大量的工作正在进行，我们也在我们的实验室里做了一些这样的工作，试图在婴儿期识别自闭症，因为现在有许多研究，其中一些工作是由我们的团队完成的，我们查看了后来被诊断为自闭症的婴儿的家庭录像。但有许多研究
have shown that between about six and 12 months of age, that the signs of autism begin to emerge in the majority of infants. And those signs could be the lack of communicative babbling. So we know, you know, during that period, babies tend to use consonant vowel sounds, you know, mama, blah, and they engage in this sort of back and forth with their parents. That is often absent or much delayed. The use of gestures, so we know that during that period, babies begin to start to use simple gestures such as bye-bye. They also develop what is called joint attention, which is a set of gestures where the baby is drawing the parents' attention to something, and they could do that, for example, by pointing at something to show them something,
研究表明，在大约六到十二个月大时，自闭症的迹象开始在大多数婴儿身上显现。这些迹象可能是缺乏交流性的咿呀学语。我们知道，在这个时期，婴儿倾向于使用辅音和元音组合，比如妈妈、吧啦，并且他们会与父母进行这种一来一往的互动。这通常是缺失的或大大延迟的。手势的使用，我们知道在这个时期，婴儿开始使用简单的手势，比如拜拜。他们还会发展出所谓的共同注意，这是一套手势，婴儿通过这些手势吸引父母对某事物的注意，例如，他们可以通过指着某样东西来向父母展示某物，
or they might be interested. If someone else points, they would follow that point and notice what others are doing. That's why we call it shared or joint attention. And those behaviors are quite diagnostic. And so we see this lack of pointing, particularly to show. So another sign could be some lack of interest in engaging with people as compared to objects. So this baby may be very interested in objects and features of the non-social environment, but maybe making less eye contact and not playing those baby games that we often see like pat a cake.
或者他们可能会感兴趣。如果其他人指向某个方向，他们会顺着那个方向看去，并注意到别人在做什么。这就是为什么我们称之为共享或共同注意。这些行为具有相当强的诊断意义。因此，我们看到这种缺乏指指点点的现象，特别是为了展示而指。另一个迹象可能是与人交往的兴趣不如对物体的兴趣。所以这个婴儿可能对物体和非社会环境的特征非常感兴趣，但可能眼神接触较少，也没有玩那些我们经常看到的婴儿游戏，比如拍手歌。
And so those and even the sensory sensitivities have been. noticed in these young babies. So we should be able to pick up on autism during the infant period, and we're working on a lot of different ways that we may be able to do that. Some of those are ways of measuring behaviors. Other ways are trying to see whether we could detect early changes in the way the brain is working and functioning, and I'm happy to talk about those. but there's a lot of work on looking at these brain-based, but are called biomarkers, to see whether we can detect these even before we might be able to diagnose the full syndrome, which would be, you know, not until, say, 16 to 18 or 24 months of age.
因此，这些甚至感觉敏感性也在这些小婴儿身上被注意到。所以我们应该能够在婴儿期就发现自闭症，并且我们正在研究许多不同的方法来实现这一点。其中一些是测量行为的方法。其他方法则是试图看我们是否能够检测到大脑工作和功能方式的早期变化，我很高兴谈论这些。但是有大量关于研究这些基于大脑的、被称为生物标志物的工作，看看我们是否能够在我们能够诊断出完整综合征之前就检测到这些，这通常要等到16到18个月或24个月大。
When you're looking for brain-based biomarkers in very young children, how do you do that in a lab? I mean, how do you take a baby that's six months old and do, you know, an fMRI, for example? You can hardly do that with adults sometimes. Actually, babies are easier than adults. Yes, for us that do brain research, it's interesting that babies, they take naps and they, you know, they are actually much easier than the hardest period in terms of some of these measures is the toddler period where they want to, you know, get up and wiggle around.
当你寻找非常幼小的儿童的大脑生物标志物时，你在实验室里是怎么做到的？我的意思是，你怎么能拿一个六个月大的婴儿去做核磁共振（fMRI）呢？有时连成年人都很难做到这一点。事实上，婴儿比成年人更容易。是的，对于我们这些做大脑研究的人来说，有趣的是婴儿会打瞌睡，而且他们，实际上容易得多。就其中一些测量而言，最困难的时期是幼儿期，那时他们想要站起来到处扭动。
But there are lots of different ways. of studying the brain in infants. And most of the studies to date have followed infants who have an older sibling with autism that's already been diagnosed because we know that when there's one child in the family that's been diagnosed that the probability that the second child will have autism is about one in five. So that is a much higher rate. And so by following these what are called high likelihood infants prospectively and then taking brain measures and behavior measures during infants, infancy, we can then follow them longitudinally.
但是有很多不同的方法来研究婴儿的大脑。迄今为止的大多数研究都追踪了那些有已经确诊自闭症的年长哥哥姐姐的婴儿，因为我们知道，当家里有一个孩子被确诊时，第二个孩子患自闭症的概率大约是五分之一。所以这个比例要高得多。因此，通过前瞻性地追踪这些所谓的具有高可能性婴儿，并在婴儿期进行大脑测量和行为测量，我们就可以对他们进行纵向追踪。
And then when that one in five is diagnosed with autism, we can look backwards and say, oh, well, what was different about their brain when we made those early measures? So that's the ways that the studies are mostly done. And in terms of the measures, there's been quite a bit of research looking at the development of the structure of the brain using MRI. So these are large collaborative studies occurring at multiple universities. In fact, one of the biggest studies is led by my colleague Joseph Piven, who's a psychiatrist down the road. at UNC, Chapel Hill, because I'm at Duke, not very close by. And so he, for the last several years, has been falling very large samples of high-risk infants or high- likelihood infants and then doing repeat MRIs to watch how the brain
然后，当这五分之一的孩子被确诊为自闭症时，我们可以回过头来说，哦，当我们进行早期测量时，他们的大脑有什么不同？这就是这些研究的主要进行方式。在测量方面，有相当多的研究使用磁共振成像（MRI）来观察大脑结构的发展。这些是在多所大学进行的大型合作研究。事实上，其中最大的一项研究由我的同事约瑟夫·皮文（Joseph Piven）领导，他是一位就在附近的北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的精神病学家，因为我在杜克大学，离得不太远。因此，在过去的几年里，他一直在追踪非常大样本的高危婴儿或高可能性婴儿，然后进行重复的MRI检查，以观察大脑是如何
develops. And what he's found, he and his team, is that between six and 12 months of age that the white matter of the brain. So this is the part of the brain that helps different parts of the brain communicate with each other. So this is the myelin that goes around the connections of the brain that makes it more efficient in terms of the ability to communicate between two brain regions. And what they found is that there's differences in the development of this white matter that can be seen by six to 12 months of age. And essentially, what people are finding is that autism is a condition that affects the
发育的。他和他的团队发现，在六到十二个月大之间，大脑的白质。所以这是大脑中帮助不同区域相互交流的部分。也就是围绕在大脑连接周围的髓鞘，这使得它在两个大脑区域之间进行交流的能力方面更有效率。他们发现这种白质的发育存在差异，在六到十二个月大时就可以看到。本质上，人们发现自闭症是一种影响
neuroconnectivity across different regions of the brain and these white matter fiber tracks. And if you think about the behaviors that are affected by autism, which mostly is a around social interaction and communication. Those behaviors require the precise coordination across multiple brain regions. So think about, for example, if you're involved in, say, a conversation with another person, you're watching their facial gestures,
大脑不同区域之间神经连接以及这些白质纤维束的病症。如果你想想受自闭症影响的行为，主要围绕社会交往和沟通。这些行为需要多个大脑区域之间的精确协调。例如，如果你参与了一场与另一个人的对话，你在观察他们的面部手势，
you're listening to the sound of their voice, you're anticipating the timing of the back and forth of the conversation, you're using your motor cortex, to say words, for example. So even something like a conversation requires, you know, the frontal lobe, the visual cortex, the speech areas in auditory cortex, the motor cortex. And these all have to be functioning in precise coordination.
你在听他们声音的语调，你在预测对话一来一往的时机，你正在使用你的运动皮层来发音，等等。因此，即使像对话这样简单的事情也需要额叶、视觉皮层、听觉皮层的言语区、运动皮层的参与。所有这些都必须在精确协调下运作。
And so we do think that autism affects the ability of the different brain regions to be coordinated in a way to allow us to. engage in these very complex behaviors. Now, I do want to take the opportunity here, though, to stress that autism also is associated with many positive traits, skills, and talents, and that it's, you know, very likely that the sort of sacrifice of the ability to do some of these, you know, behaviors that are important, obviously social interaction and communication. but it also offers the opportunity to be able to really view the world in a very different and unique way
因此，我们确实认为自闭症会影响不同大脑区域以某种方式进行协调的能力，从而使我们能够参与这些非常复杂的行为。现在，我确实想借此机会强调，自闭症也与许多积极的特质、技能和天赋有关，而且，牺牲做某些这些显然对社会交往和沟通很重要的行为的能力，很有可能，它也提供了一个真正以非常不同和独特的方式看待世界的机会，
and to have very important and special talents. And it probably has to do with the fact that there's probably large areas of the brain that are now able to be used for other things, you know, whether it's mathematics or music or art or physics. You know, so, you know, it's important to. to really think about autism is a brain difference that then comes with challenges, to be sure, but also with many very important and special strengths and talents as well. Now, you published a study in February that found that an artificial intelligence algorithm could detect autism risk by screening infant's medical records right from the first month of life.
并拥有非常重要和特殊的才能。这可能与大脑中可能有很大一部分现在能够用于其他事情有关，无论是数学、音乐、艺术还是物理。所以，真正把自闭症看作是一种伴随着挑战的大脑差异是很重要的，这是肯定的，但也伴随着许多非常重要和特殊的优势和才能。现在，你在二月份发表了一项研究，发现人工智能算法可以通过筛查婴儿从出生第一个月开始的医疗记录来检测自闭症风险。
that's pretty incredible. How does that work? So we have been, we were awarded a grant from the National Institutes of Health that challenged us to come up with ways of screening for autism in babies. Because as I said before, it's clear that autism starts in infancy. And we want to begin, you know, intervention, services and support is as early as possible. possible. And so we actually have been attacking this two ways. So one is to gather information about the baby's health care record to see if there are clues in terms of how the infant is utilizing the health care system that might indicate that that baby would be more likely
这真是不可思议。这是如何运作的？所以我们一直，我们获得了国立卫生研究院的一项资助，该资助向我们发起挑战，要求我们想出在婴儿期筛查自闭症的方法。因为正如我之前所说，很明显自闭症始于婴儿期。我们希望尽早开始干预服务和支持。所以我们实际上一直在从两个方面攻克这个难题。一个是收集关于婴儿医疗保健记录的信息，看看是否有关于婴儿如何利用医疗保健系统的线索，这些线索可能表明这个婴儿更有可能
to have a later diagnosis of autism. And the reason why we thought this might work, is because autism is associated with quite a few medical conditions. So people think about autism as a behavioral health condition, and it is, but it's also a physical health condition. So, for example, many people diagnosed with autism also have difficulties with the GI system. So in babies, this could be reflux, it could be diarrhea. constipation, other GI-related conditions. And actually in our studies, we are finding that these start very early within the first three months of life. So this is happening before we even start to see changes in behavior.
在晚些时候被诊断出患有自闭症。我们认为这会起作用的原因是，自闭症与相当多的医疗状况有关。因此，人们认为自闭症是一种行为健康状况，确实如此，但它也是一种身体健康状况。例如，许多被诊断为自闭症的人也有胃肠系统方面的困难。在婴儿身上，这可能是反流、腹泻、便秘或其他与胃肠相关的疾病。事实上，在我们的研究中，我们发现这些在生命的前三个月内就开始了。所以这甚至在我们开始看到行为变化之前就发生了。
A second one is differences in the way the motor system is developed. So we find that even during the first year of life, that babies who are going to go on to have a diagnosis of autism are visiting the physical therapist for difficulties in their motor development that are affected in the first year. We also see higher rates of sleep disruptions, trouble establishing a circadian rhythm. And in fact, there's been research that shows that some of the genetics, that genetic genes that are responsible for regulating our circadian rhythm. may contribute to autism. So there are other conditions as well,
第二个是运动系统发育方式的差异。我们发现，甚至在生命的第一年里，那些后来被诊断为自闭症的婴儿就会因为在第一年受到影响的运动发育困难而去看物理治疗师。我们还看到更高比例的睡眠紊乱，难以建立昼夜节律。事实上，有研究表明，一些负责调节我们昼夜节律的遗传基因可能会导致自闭症。所以还有其他情况，
but what we found was that if we can study how the parent is bringing their baby to receive these medical services in the first year of life, that we can do a pretty good job of predicting, even in the first month, that this baby will have a higher likelihood of a diagnosis of autism. And the idea here is that if, you know, there's no way that a pediatrician could be, well, it would be very difficult for the pediatrician to have to look through and try to understand all of these patterns of health care utilization when the pediatricians say seeing the baby for a well-child visit. So, but the computer can do this, right? So we can have the computer gathering all of this health-related data.
但我们发现，如果我们能研究父母是如何带他们的婴儿在生命第一年接受这些医疗服务的，我们就能做得很好，甚至在第一个月就能预测出这个婴儿患自闭症诊断的可能性更高。这里的想法是，如果，儿科医生不可能，或者说儿科医生要去看并试图理解当儿科医生看到婴儿进行健康儿童访问时的所有这些医疗保健利用模式将是非常困难的。但是计算机可以做到这一点，对吧？所以我们可以让计算机收集所有这些与健康相关的数据。
It could be all the diagnostic codes, all the types of visits, all the medications, all the procedures, and then use artificial intelligence or machine learning to combine all of these data into an algorithm that then is predictive of a particular diagnosis, in this case, autism. And we've been looking at the same thing for ADHD, by the way, and we find that these can be distinguished. So, for example, a baby who is going to have a later diagnosis of autism is going to be much more likely to have visited the emergency room by age one. And this may have to do, again, with that impulsive behavior, risk-taking, you know, other things that might lead to accidents, right, that would end up in an emergency room. So, you know, there's just a lot of information there that that then can. you know, help us to let the pediatrician know that they need to be paying special attention to this baby and monitoring the baby's development very closely.
它可以是所有的诊断代码、所有的就诊类型、所有的药物、所有的程序，然后使用人工智能或机器学习将所有这些数据组合成一个算法，从而预测特定的诊断，在本例中是自闭症。顺便说一句，我们一直在研究多动症（ADHD）的同样事情，我们发现这些是可以区分的。例如，一个后来会被诊断为自闭症的婴儿，到一岁时去急诊室的可能性要大得多。这可能再次与冲动行为、冒险行为有关，或其他可能导致最终进入急诊室的事故有关。所以，那里有很多信息可以帮助我们让儿科医生知道他们需要特别关注这个婴儿并非常密切地监测婴儿的发育。
And this information can be combined with what is called clinical decision support. So this is a very active field now in healthcare where pediatricians and other providers are provided with information about whether or you. this patient, you know, is a higher likelihood of developing, you know, a condition. It could be a heart-related condition, in this case, autism. And then also providing the physician with, well, what should they do about it? So giving the physician through the computer advice about, okay, this means that, you know, you may want to make a referral for such and such, or depending on the age, you may actually want to refer for a diagnostic evaluation. But, you know,
这些信息可以与所谓的临床决策支持相结合。这现在是医疗保健领域一个非常活跃的领域，儿科医生和其他提供者会获得有关该患者是否更有可能患某种疾病的信息。这可能是心脏相关的疾病，在本例中是自闭症。然后还向医生提供他们应该对此做些什么。因此，通过计算机向医生提供建议，好吧，这意味着你可能想进行某某转诊，或者根据年龄，你实际上可能想转诊进行诊断评估。但是，
you know, here's ways that you can follow this baby and screen, you know, to see if the behaviors are merging. So that was one approach. And by the way, that work was led by my colleague Matthew Englehard, who is both a physician and a biostatistician. So he combines both medicine and data science to do this really phenomenal work. And we're now, we've received more funding to continue to expand upon. this work. And then the second approach that we've been using is to use the computer to measure
这里有你可以关注这个婴儿并进行筛查的方法，看看这些行为是否正在显现。所以这是一种方法。顺便说一句，这项工作由我的同事马修·恩格尔哈德（Matthew Engelhard）领导，他既是一名医生又是一名生物统计学家。因此，他结合了医学和数据科学来完成这项非常了不起的工作。我们现在，我们已经获得了更多的资金，继续扩大这项工作。我们一直在使用的第二种方法是使用计算机来测量
those early behavioral signs. So this work began to try to improve our ways of screening for autism. So currently, the American Academy of Pediatrics recommends that all toddlers be screened universally for autism at their 18 and 24 month visit. And remember, that's the age where we can make a diagnosis. So, you know, it's good in terms of you can have, you know, a diagnostic evaluation at that age. But it's not so good in the sense that what happens is that they often get screened. And then it takes time to make the referral. Then they get on a waiting list for a diagnosis.
那些早期的行为迹象。这项工作开始于试图改进我们筛查自闭症的方法。目前，美国儿科学会建议所有幼儿在18个月和24个月的体检时进行普遍的自闭症筛查。请记住，这是我们可以做出诊断的年龄。所以，就你可以在那个年龄进行诊断评估而言，这很好。但从某种意义上说，它不是很好，因为经常发生的情况是他们接受了筛查，然后需要时间来进行转诊，然后他们进入诊断等待名单，
and there's often a long waiting list, and then after they get the diagnosis, they're on another waiting list to get the intervention. So, you know, there can be a year or before intervention begins. So now we're looking at 36, you know, or even, you know, 48 months of age. So we really want to shift all of that earlier. But there was problems with this screening approach.
而且通常有很长的等待名单，然后在他们得到诊断后，他们又在另一个等待名单上等待干预。所以，干预开始前可能会有一年的时间。所以现在我们看到的是36个月甚至48个月大。所以我们真的很想把所有这些都提前。但这种筛查方法存在问题。
So typically how this is done at 18. in 24 months is with a parent questionnaire. And it's a simple questionnaire given universally, for example, here at Duke in primary care, where you ask the parents about 20 questions that have to do with those behaviors that I mentioned earlier. Is your child pointing? Are they using words? Are they interested in games?
通常在18和24个月时这是通过父母问卷完成的。这是一个在初级保健中普遍发放的简单问卷，例如在这里的杜克大学，你向父母询问大约20个与我前面提到的那些行为有关的问题。你的孩子会指吗？他们在用词吗？他们对游戏感兴趣吗？
Do they imitate you? So questions like that. And then depending on, you know, how many yeses, or knows in this. case that the parent says, then they would be considered to have a higher likelihood of autism, and hopefully the provider would make a referral. Now, one of the interesting findings is that most pediatricians still don't make a referral. About 60% of the time, they, even with a positive screen on a parent questionnaire, they don't make a referral. They take a wait and see approach. And part of it has to do with just their lack of confidence and interpreting the information. And part of it
他们模仿你吗？诸如此类的问题。然后根据父母回答的是或否的数量，他们将被认为患自闭症的可能性更高，希望医疗提供者会进行转诊。现在，一个有趣的发现是大多数儿科医生仍然没有进行转诊。大约60%的时候，即使父母问卷筛查呈阳性，他们也没有进行转诊。他们采取观望态度。部分原因与他们对解释信息的缺乏信心有关，部分原因
may have to do with the difficulty in finding services and some reluctance to, you know, send the parent on a journey that that can be very frustrating and costly. Or telling the parent that they think that the child is on the spectrum and then maybe being wrong, right? I mean, they could be. Yes, absolutely. Yeah. And I think that's an important point too, because so the most common questionnaire is called the modified checklist for autism and toddlers or the mchat. And by the way, we are so happy we have the M-chat and we are so happy that pediatricians use it. So I'm not in any way wanting to say we should discourage use of the M-chat. But if the child is referred, they will have about a 50-50 chance of having a diagnosis of autism.
可能与寻找服务的困难有关，并且有些不愿意让父母踏上一段可能非常令人沮丧和昂贵的旅程。或者告诉父母他们认为孩子在谱系上，然后可能是错的，对吧？我的意思是，他们可能是。是的，绝对是。是的。我认为这也是一个重要点，因为最常见的问卷被称为自闭症幼儿改良检查清单（M-chat）。顺便说一句，我们很高兴我们有M-chat，我们很高兴儿科医生使用它。所以我绝不是想说我们应该阻止使用M-chat。但是如果孩子被转诊，他们患自闭症的几率大约是百分之五十对五十。
So that does mean that there will be some, you know, false positives, many people waiting to get a diagnosis that don't need to and adding to those long wait lists. So all of that, I think, is contributing to this reluctance to make a referral. But there were other problems, or there are other problems as well. So the M-Chat does not work as well with families of color. So we don't completely understand it, but there are. reasons why from different cultures that have different attitudes around providing information or how they interpret information. The other thing is that it does require literacy and understanding of child development. And, you know, many parents may not have those skills. And so for those reasons,
这意味着会有一些假阳性，许多人等待诊断却并不需要，这加剧了本已很长的等待名单。所以所有这些，我认为，都导致了人们对进行转诊的迟疑。但还有其他问题，或者说也存在其他问题。M-Chat量表对有色人种家庭的适用效果并不那么好。我们虽然没有完全理解原因，但确实存在一些原因，源于不同文化对提供信息的态度或对信息的解释方式有所不同。另一个问题是，它确实需要识字能力和对儿童发展的理解。你知道，许多家长可能并不具备这些技能。因此，基于这些原因，
when it's used in real world settings like primary care, it's really not performing as well as it should. It also is not as good at picking up autism and girls. So what we wanted to do was to develop a methodology where we could directly observe the child's behavior. Because we know, I mean, autism is a behavioral diagnosis. So we should be able to directly observe what the child is doing and try to pick up on the behavioral signs. And some people have tried to have the pediatrician do this, but honestly, they don't have the time. And also, they have so many things that they're screening for and concerned about. They don't have a time to do a diagnostic assessment as part of their work. while child 15-minute off and visit.
当它被用于初级保健等现实场景时，它的表现确实不如预期。它在识别自闭症女童方面的效果也不够好。因此，我们想要开发一种方法，能够直接观察儿童的行为。因为我们知道，自闭症是一种行为诊断。所以我们应该能够直接观察儿童的行为，并尝试捕捉这些行为迹象。有些人曾试图让儿科医生这样做，但老实说，他们没有时间。而且，他们有太多需要筛查和关注的事情。在他们常规的15分钟门诊时间内，他们没有时间进行诊断评估。
So we decided to try to use a technique called computer vision analysis, which is a way of the computer with a computer, using a computer to measure behavior. And the way this works is we designed an app, and this can be downloaded on a smartphone or a tablet. And the app displays a set of short. movies. And these movies were strategically designed by our team to elicit autism-related behaviors. So to elicit facial expressions and vocalizations, to assess, to be able to see whether
因此，我们决定尝试使用一种名为计算机视觉分析的技术，这是一种通过计算机来测量行为的方法。它的工作原理是，我们设计了一款应用程序，可以下载到智能手机或平板电脑上。该应用程序会播放一组简短的视频。这些视频由我们的团队经过精心设计，旨在引发与自闭症相关的行为。也就是引发面部表情和发声，以便进行评估，看看
the baby is more interested in looking at objects versus people. And so these, again, were very carefully designed. So the baby watches these brief movies. It's all done within less than 10 minutes. And the camera that's in the device, whether it's a smartphone or a tablet, is recording the baby's responses. Then the engineering team uses computer vision to automatically code a wide range of behaviors.
婴儿是对看物体更感兴趣，还是对看人更感兴趣。所以这些同样是经过非常精心设计的。因此，婴儿观看这些简短的视频。整个过程在不到10分钟内完成。设备（无论是智能手机还是平板电脑）内置的摄像头会记录婴儿的反应。然后，工程团队利用计算机视觉自动对广泛的行为进行编码。
So a computer can code, facial expressions, vocalizations, head turns, body movements. You can do all of this. And what's really amazing is it can do it better than a human. And I truly believe this. And I, of course, have been observing behavior as a psychologist my entire career and coding a lot of behavior. But I'll give you an example. So one of the early signs is not orienting when your name is called.
因此，计算机可以对面部表情、发声、转头、身体动作进行编码。你可以做到这一切。真正惊人的是，它甚至能做得比人类更好。我对此深信不疑。当然，作为一名心理学家，我整个职业生涯都在观察行为，并对大量行为进行编码。但我举个例子。早期的征兆之一，就是在听到自己的名字时没有反应。
So while the baby is watching the movies, someone behind them actually calls their name. And, you know, the baby will typically turn their head. And a computer can precisely measure that. And what we found was that, indeed, that babies who then later had a diagnosis of autism did not turn their head as frequently. But some of them did turn their head. And what we found was that when they turned their head, they did a second delayed compared to the neurotypical babies. And there's no way a clinician could have seen that.
因此，当婴儿观看视频时，他们身后的人会叫他们的名字。通常情况下，婴儿会转过头去。而计算机可以精确地测量这一点。我们发现，事实上，后来被诊断出患有自闭症的婴儿转头的频率确实没有那么高。但其中一些婴儿确实转头了。我们发现，当他们转头时，与神经典型婴儿相比，他们会有大约一秒钟的延迟。临床医生是绝不可能看出这一点的。
So the clinician would have said the baby doesn't have that sign, but the computer was able to do this at a much higher resolution. So we have now validated this in the 18 to 24 month age. And we also have just completed a study where we've shown that this can be done at home. So parents can download the app at home and those data can be sent to the pediatrician ahead of time right before the visit so that they have. have assessments of the child behaviors that could also be done over time to track behavioral development. And the study we're doing now is starting at six months of age and then following babies longitudinally and they were repeating the app over time and they will see whether this can be used to eventually pick up on signs in, you know, in babies who then will have a diagnosis
因此，临床医生可能会说这个婴儿没有这种征兆，但计算机能够以高得多的分辨率做到这一点。所以我们现在已经在18到24个月的年龄段对这一点进行了验证。我们还刚刚完成了一项研究，表明这可以在家中完成。因此家长可以在家里下载应用程序，这些数据可以在访问前提前发送给儿科医生，以便他们掌握儿童行为的评估结果，并且可以随着时间的推移进行评估，以追踪行为发展。我们目前正在进行的研究是从6个月大开始，然后对婴儿进行纵向追踪，随着时间的推移重复使用该应用程序，看看这是否最终能用于及早发现那些随后会被诊断为
of autism. So I think it's, you know, I started. my career by trying to understand autism and infants by looking at home videotapes that parents had gathered. And now I'm using artificial intelligence and computer science to measure these on an app that's on a smartphone. So I would have never imagined that. Technology. You just can't keep up with it. It's amazing. So let me ask you one wrap-up question, which has to do with why the early diagnosis is important. And obviously, we've been talking about the concept of interventions of that I actually describing them. But if a parent gets the diagnosis early enough, what is it that the parent should then do to help the child? Yeah, thank you for that question, because that is,
自闭症的婴儿的征兆。所以我想，我职业生涯的开始是通过观看家长收集的家庭录像来试图了解婴儿自闭症。而现在我正在使用人工智能和计算机科学在智能手机的应用程序上测量这些。我以前从未想象过这一点。科技发展太快，你简直无法跟上。这太神奇了。让我问你最后一个问题，这与为什么早期诊断很重要有关。显然，我们一直在讨论干预的概念，我实际上也描述了它们。但是，如果家长足够早地得到诊断，家长接下来应该做什么来帮助孩子呢？是的，谢谢你提出这个问题，因为这，
you know, really the crux of the matter. The reason why we want to detect autism early is to provide services and intervention. So I'll describe a type of intervention that is very commonly used now. These are a class of interventions called naturalistic developmental behavioral interventions. They evolved out of traditional applied behavior analysis, which is a technique that has been used for many years as an intervention model. This is sort of a newer version that is much more play-based, much more naturalistic. We follow the infant or the toddler's lead and capitalize on their interests and preferences, which makes the therapy much more engaging, both for the child and the parent. But essentially, these interventions use play and naturalistic interventions
你知道，这才是问题的关键。我们想要早期发现自闭症的原因是为了提供服务和干预。我将介绍一种目前非常常用的干预类型。这是一类被称为自然主义发展性行为干预的干预措施。它们从传统的应用行为分析演变而来，后者是一种作为干预模型使用了多年的技术。这是一种更新的版本，基于更多游戏化、更多自然主义的元素。我们顺应婴儿或幼儿的意愿，利用他们的兴趣和偏好，这使得治疗对于孩子和家长来说都更具吸引力。但本质上，这些干预措施利用游戏和自然主义干预
to facilitate the babies, first of all, interest in other people. So to bring the baby's attention back to people. Because remember, this infant or toddler is now much more interested in toys and the world of objects than people. But there are ways of using play and inserting yourself into the interests of the baby or the child where you become part of their world. and then they will naturally start to be interested in you and looking at you. Once that happens, then we again use these techniques to teach the infant or the toddler how to use gestures, how to communicate through a set of strategies that can be taught
来首先促进婴儿对其他人的兴趣。也就是把婴儿的注意力重新吸引到人身上。因为记住，这个婴儿或幼儿现在对玩具和物体世界的兴趣远远大于对人的兴趣。但有通过利用游戏并将你自己融入婴儿或孩子的兴趣中的方法，让你成为他们世界的一部分，然后他们会自然地开始对你感兴趣并看着你。一旦发生这种情况，我们就会再次利用这些技术来教婴儿或幼儿如何使用手势，如何通过一套可以教授给
to parents to use at home or, you know, delivered by a therapist. And so these parent, what are called parent mediated therapies are ones where we work with the parent to learn these strategies that they can use during their everyday activity. So if you think about a neurotypical infant, we don't sit them down and say, I'm going to teach you now how to speak or I'm going to teach you how to recognize that this is a smile. it happens during every interaction during the day is an opportunity for learning during meal time and bath time at the park. And so similarly, these interventions that are taught to parents are ones where the parents
家长在家里使用或由治疗师提供的策略来进行交流。因此，这些被称为家长介导的疗法是这样的：我们与家长合作学习这些策略，以便他们在日常活动中使用。所以如果你想想一个神经典型的婴儿，我们不会让他们坐下来说：我现在要教你如何说话，或者我要教你如何识别这是一个微笑。这发生在日常的每一次互动中，吃饭时间、洗澡时间、在公园里，都是学习的机会。因此，同样地，教给家长的这些干预措施是家长
can use these strategies just throughout their everyday activities. So we have a book, for example, it's called an early start for your child with autism, and it is written for parents and it teaches them a wide range of strategies they can use. And it has to do with things like how do you position yourself. For example, when you sit down to read a book with your baby or your child, you're not going to sit them on your lap, you know, where they're faced away from you. You're going to sit them where they're faced forward to you. So you're going to have yourself in their zone of proximity.
可以在整个日常活动中随时使用这些策略。例如，我们有一本书，叫做《自闭症儿童早期启蒙指南》，它是为家长写的，教给他们各种各样的策略。它涉及到比如你如何调整自己的体位。例如，当你坐下来和你的婴儿或孩子一起读书时，你不会把他们放在你的腿上，背对著你。你会让他们面对着你坐。所以你要让自己处于他们的邻近区内。
and also in their spotlight, so to speak. Then you're going to learn how to kind of capitalize on the things that the babies is interested in to start to facilitate things like turn-taking. You're going to do a lot of imitation of the babies or the toddler's vocalizations and actions. So we find that, let's say that this two-year-old is banging on something and not looking, at you. If you have a drum two and you bang at the second same time, that two-year-old with autism is going to be start looking at you, playing with it. And pretty soon, you're in a fun back-and-forth game where you're both, you know, playing the jumps together. And so these are
并且可以说是进入他们的聚光灯下。然后你将学习如何利用婴儿感兴趣的事物来促进诸如轮流互动的事情。你会大量模仿婴儿或幼儿的发声和动作。所以我们发现，比方说这个两岁的孩子在敲打某样东西却没有看着你。如果你也有一个鼓并在同一时间敲击，那个患有自闭症的两岁孩子就会开始看着你，并一起玩耍。很快，你们就会陷入一个有趣的来回游戏中，你们俩都在一起玩鼓。所以这些
relatively easy to learn. Parents are very good at learning them. And they've been shown to really facilitate early social and communication development. So we're very excited about, you know, parents using these. And again, they can be delivered by therapists as well. And they can make a huge difference in children's outcomes. Well, Dr. Dawson, I want to thank you for joining me. This has been really interesting. And I'm sure that our listeners are going to learn a lot from hearing from you. So thank you. Oh, it's been my pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
相对容易学习。家长非常擅长学习这些。并且事实证明它们确实能促进早期的社交和沟通发展。所以我们对家长使用这些感到非常兴奋。同样，它们也可以由治疗师提供。它们可以对儿童的发育结果产生巨大的影响。好的，道森博士，我想感谢你加入我的节目。这真的非常有趣。我相信我们的听众会从听取你的分享中学到很多。谢谢你。哦，这是我的荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 www.parentingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学纵谈》先前的节目，也可以在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。
And again, we'd like to hear from you about what you think about this podcast and what you'd like to hear from us. So please go to our website, speakingof psychology.org, and look for a link to the listener's survey. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyen. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次感谢您，我们很想听听您对这档播客的看法以及您希望听到我们探讨什么内容。因此，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org，并寻找指向听众调查的链接。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingof psychology at APA。本期《心理学纵谈》由 Lee Winerman 制作。我们的音频剪辑师是 Chris Kondyen。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。